[Musique]
notre vision devient le plus important
projet de développement durable toutes
parts
je ne vois pas pourquoi nous québécois
ne savions pas justement la hauteur de
ce territoire immense émotion et j y
avais pas en de mer qu'ils aillent est
ce que je veux c'est donner aux
québécois un projet qui est vraiment à
la hauteur du tout le temps j'ai
problème qu'avait
qu'est ce que ça vous les
[Musique]
loin des gisements nordiques que des
gens d'affaires affûtent leurs projets
d'investissement le premier ministre
charest lui multiplie les conférences de
présentation de son plan nord dans la
salle ce jour-là montréal des centaines
d'entrepreneurs occupent toutes les
tables à près de 1000 $ la table parmi
les hommes d'affaires présents pierre
coulombe
le conseiller en assurance et rentes
collectives rien à voir en principe avec
le plan nord qui a couleurs méconnu
toutefois dans les milieux politiques
jusqu'en 2008 il était l'organisateur en
chef au québec du parti conservateur de
stephen harper il était aussi considéré
comme un proche du parti libéral du
québec dans les années 80 pierre
coulombe a été attaché politique au sein
du gouvernement de brown
comme lui l'ong est un petit gars de la
côte nord c'est avec lui qu'il a fait
ses débuts en politique comme
organisateur à des commandes
après plus de 25 ans politique pierre
coulombe offre de monnayer de prétendus
contacts privilégiés pour développer des
projets tant cadre du plan nord
[Musique]
maxime berreby c'est moi qui ai marre de
la politique
moi je peux te donner pas de qualité je
connais quelqu'un député pierre coulombe
est un homme de l'ombre
en 2006 il a été un des artisans de la
percée électorale des troupes de stephen
harper au québec
mais quelques mois plus tard son nom se
retrouve dans les journaux dans un
scandale concernant une méthode
électorale de financement qui
contournait les règles d'élection canada
coup l'homme s'en est sorti sans
accusation ni condamnation
aujourd'hui il se vante d'avoir des
contacts politiques en particulier un
ancien du parti conservateur qui lui
devrait grand service à zurich était
reçu trois semaines des terrains
on est sauvé je vous en conter ça vous a
compté pour l'autre j'aurais jeté à
l'eau ces princesses michel pierre
tarbouriech conquiert le titre besoin
d'aidé moi a ajouté je te dise estime
dont le levier cher pierre coulon et une
beau parleur watine les moyens de ses
ambitions
nous avons été mis sur sa piste il ya un
an par une source confidentielle
nous avons des enregistrements de
plusieurs rencontres où il tente de
monnayer de l'information privilégiée
sur le plan nord auprès d'un individu se
prétendant être à la tête d'un groupe
d'investisseurs
une des premières rencontres a lieu le 6
octobre dernier dans une chambre d'hôtel
de montréal pierre coulombe ce point à
l'heure au rendez vous les deux jambes
ont discuté pendant près de deux heures
tous dans la discussion pierre couleurs
m'annonce à son interlocuteur michel
avoir fait ses devoirs
rencontre avec le ministre responsable
des mines serge simard dit ne pas
connaître pierre coulombe et donc ne pas
l'avoir rencontré les plusieurs fois
durant la conversation pierre coulombe
se vante d'avoir eu des contacts répétés
et privilégié avec une personne
travaillant à son bureau et avec de
nombreux autres intervenants publics
avec aliens vs
son plein fouet bien que
super eric et moi c'est pas aussi pour
décider que tel mais qu'aucun agent de
vienne pour la bande c'est pas bien
parce que pouvoir la tête c'est tout ce
qui est important pour renault
ça c'est d'avoir la meilleure formation
passée à la rencontre de l'hôtel pierre
coulon parle maintenant des titres
miniers et clem mais aussi de l'accès
aux infrastructures routières ou
ferroviaires
sans elle impossible d'exploiter une
mine du nord est ce que le ministère il
les connaît les bons clubs le font face
à de sobres
encore
les musiques qui font se sentir les
concessions minières
puis on sait à peu près où la boue de
vos pensées pour les gros et qu'on vous
serez en train de s'installer là s'il ya
des affaires d'un taux de taux pas loin
là ça devient intéressant
on parle depuis plusieurs mois de la
création de la société du plan nord
pierre coulon lui y voit une occasion en
or pour affirmer sur les autres contacts
gérer tout seul devant un conseil
d'administration
maintenant mon nom avec le président je
la voyais cours du conseil des ministres
assurent ce que j'ai su que reçoit le
ministre
mais pour sûr mais poids précis
là-dessus car le pouvoir
exposé très bonne année
est ce qu'il va être bon
- comet
c'est vrai qu'une éducation politique
jean ping dans la conversation
l'histoire des possibles contacts
revient sans cesse
c'est alors que la question des
récompenses à donner éventuellement est
abordé par l'interlocuteur de pierre
coulombe
une relation de confiance moi j'étais
crevé
sont un problème d'éducation
politique de taille au détour d'un sacré
n'est peut-être cancérogène carbone
c'est l'homme fait restaurer même les
causes sont honda privée et du seuil des
conséquences à des efforts mais il
attend des informations qu'on voulait je
l'étais du cabinet mais nestor savons
bien mon pot pourri des dérives pas fait
des années que je ne savais pas comme ça
mais comme dit comme ça
vrai
en entreprise
donc ça
j'aime quand gm sera chaud
du langage des côtes
illustration réserver sa demande
ça allait mais le par année on souhaite
ou conseil d'administration au lycée
sainte-anne
dominion à l'année oui lui est propre et
on repart mis en oeuvre
d'avoir des gars pas se marier à dire le
terme
c'est une façon parce qu'on peut pas moi
je crois je pensais voir
recette
c'est surtout un des policiers ont
c'est trop dangereux quand il dit c'est
parfaitement légal intelligent
parfaitement illégal
simon roy un spécialiste de la lutte
contre la criminalité financière et
choqué des propos de biens coulombe
si vous êtes à quelqu'un écoute et
donnez moi quelque chose maintenant
et quand vous quitterez la politique
faite vous empêche prenez soin de vous
ce que le terme d'une chasse interdite
donc quand monsieur cool on me dit que
c'est parfaitement légal manifestement
il ya parfaitement tort nous avons aussi
fait entendre des extraits des propos de
pierre coulombe à ce spécialiste de
l'éthique en administration publique qui
enseigne dans les plus grandes
universités au monde
il n'est pas étonné pour moi ça c'est ça
soulève un peu la couverture sur un
phénomène qu'on commence à identifier de
plus en plus en sciences politiques ou
en sociologie
c'est à dire le fait qu' il ya une
interprétation de plus en plus forte
entre le milieu des grandes corporations
leur conseil d'administration qu'ils
sont colonisées par d'anciens
politiciens et surtout du personnel
politique issue des cabinets politiques
et on voit donc qu'il ya un retour
d'ascenseur de plus en plus rien
après la pause pierre coulombe at il les
moyens de ses ambitions
[Musique]
fin octobre 2011 trois semaines après
leur première rencontre les deux
discutent à nouveau dans une chambre
d'hôtel de montréal nous caméras et
micros cachés est encore là pour tout
capté pierre coulombe reconnaît que
comme lobbyiste il doit s'enregistrer
pour chaque démarche auprès des
autorités comme l'exigé la loi
il explique alors comment contourner les
règles
[Musique]
premier comme je t'ai dit le seigneur
donne même si jamais ce dernier après
les maisons
et où je peux m'organiser pour pas été
très bonne présentation
des fois je voudrais en votre itunes
raconte avec un bel esprit tu étais au
brésil j'ai beaucoup leur histoire dans
la balle
targa gens consultaient le petit un
cocktail plus vite que la falaise
c'était qu'il y avait pas d'information
[Musique]
vérification faite de pierre coulombe et
bien enregistré comme lobbyiste
mais ce mandat n'a rien à voir avec le
plan nord
la discussion se poursuit son
interlocuteur lui sert à boire
l'atmosphère se détache
claude vannier sur des peuples il a
connu jean charest et la ged est connu
faut-il reconnu la députée
c'était le plus jeune député de
mécanismes et il était tout petit
chameau et moi j'étais chef de cabinet
du ministre et quelle je voyage un
dollar avec un pénis j'étais obligé
d'avoir un membre du parlement
vérification faite pour pierre coulombe
a bien connu jean charest durant six
années à ottawa at il participé à sa
campagne à sherbrooke en 1993
allez paquin qui était l'organisateur de
jean charest de sherbrooke ne s'en
souvient pas mais dans une conversation
téléphonique
il nous a dit connaître assez bien
monsieur coulombe tout comme monsieur
charest
on appelle ça la belgique est nouvelle
elle est bon contre grisolles pendant
que vous appelez votre palais oui tu as
de voir totalement denis saint martin
affirme que ce qu'il entend dépasse la
simple question de l'éthique ce que moi
dont je prends connaissance
on est clairement dans les zones noires
de ce qui est interdit par la loi
denis saint martin a déjà travaillé dans
un cabinet politique il n'est pas étonné
que pierre coulon ne fasse pas partie de
la garde rapprochée de jean charest j'ai
vu des gens comme ça dans les dents le
deuxième rayon s'il vous plaît de
l'artichaut métaux toujours un espèce de
inner circle qui protège ton boss et qui
fait en sorte que ces gens là sont pas
touchés par sa pierre coulon man tilt ou
acquiescé entrée au cabinet du premier
ministre comme il le prétend dans un
communiqué transmis par son porte parole
jean charest affirme avoir connu du che
coulombe en 1984 alors que ce dernier
était à l'emploi de gros buts layton le
père de jack layton qui était le voisin
du bureau de monsieur charest il ajoute
après son passage sur la scène politique
québécoise
le premier ministre n'a revu monsieur
coulombe que de façon occasionnelle dans
des événements publics ou des activités
du parti
à aucun moment le premier ministre n'a
eu de discussion avec monsieur coulombe
concernant des projets de développement
ou d'investissements relatifs au plan
nord à l'hôtel pierre coulombe prétend
contraire l'information
river gee qui vont l'avoir il n'y avait
pas de mère à qui ça y est c est rien
n'est confirmé
l'interlocuteur de pierre coulombe
s'intéresse surtout aux projets miniers
cool on lui reparle de son contact au
ministère des mines qui lui fournirait
de l'information il croit fermement que
son contact l'aidera à mettre la main
sur des terrains à chaleur ville
il ya pas mal contact 0
elle dans cette vision là le pauvre en
devient parce qu'à l'apport de la
spéculation est la bloque s'impliquer au
mois de janvier le bureau tunisie et
dans quelques mois
vérification faite
l'administratrice de schefferville a
effectivement pris sa retraite en
janvier dernier comme le prévoyait
pierre coulombe les au téléphone elle
nous a précisé que personne ne l'avait
poussé vers la porte de sortie à la fin
de la discussion les deux jeunes reparle
des récompenses à donner mais pierre
coulombe ne nomme toujours pas son
contact au ministère des mines
les chercheurs en clair c'est que notre
dame du rosaire
ça peut plus clair pour se construire
s'associer travail et de construction
aux étudiants des chercheurs de 6,6 au
delà de l'information
elle peut plus elle m'a donné le tempo
privilégie mosaïque d'allemagne
elle a peut-être qu'à sur son sol un
visage de nos jours donc pourquoi
peut-être regarder comment denis saint
martin voit dans ces extraits la
confirmation d'une pratique de plus en
plus répandue dans les pays occidentaux
c'est la pointe de l'iceberg c'est un
phénomène qu'on a longtemps soupçonné
mais qui est devenu beaucoup plus public
donc beaucoup plus visible de nos jours
par son ampleur
la discussion a duré un peu plus de deux
heures la balle est maintenant dans le
camp de pierre coulombe
il prétend pouvoir trouver un projet de
mine en se servant de ses contacts
privilégiés
après la pause jusqu'au pierre coulombe
et proche de jean charest
wood whatever
des vols
la fin
[Musique]
février 2012 ça fait quatre mois que
pierre coulombe ne donne plus de
nouvelles
le 13 février jean charest prononce une
conférence sur le plan nord au centre
des congrès de montréal
nous nous y rendons muni d'une caméra
cachée en pensant voir la pierre
coulombe et effectivement il y ait
aujourd'hui je ne vous ai parlé d'un
projet moi qui me passionne jean charest
avant son projet comme un tournant
historique pour le québec
après que la salle se soient vidées nous
suivons pierre coulombe avec notre
caméra cachée l'image n'est pas de
grande qualité mais c'est bien lui en
compagnie d'un autre lobbyiste qui sera
salué jean charest
les deux se donnent une accolade ce qui
témoigne de leur proximité le 15 mars
2012 toujours au même hôtel nos caméras
étaient encore présentes pour une ultime
rencontre cette fois ci bien cool on a
une proposition concrète affaires
concernant des titres miniers décline
[Musique]
apparu
vous ai mis la main sur des guerres des
trains 78 millions de pieds carrés pas
loin des infrastructures où il ya des
alizés cette erreur ok
l'interlocuteur de pierre coulombe une
demande alors si ce projet provient des
informations présumément privilégié
qu'il a
des contacts de woodstock dans des
seclinois donc dans ce lycée pour la
première fois pierre coulombe révèle
alors le nom de celui qui lui fournirait
des informations privilégiées
- comme quand on avait parlé de
peut-être de classe au conseil
d'administration
moi je dirais que
les voleurs
la façon dont l'équipe est fière
si tous les amis
ouais
ça va
un problème je veux protéger d'une
certaine façon personne
sûr et que les portes du bassin avec
place sur cette illustration
20 51 mais bon
discuter avec lui de quoi une place au
français ou à des options vérification
faite pierre gaudreau existe bel et bien
il travaille avec le ministre des mines
serge simard et à ma gauche monsieur
pierre mon plus proche collaborateur
mais julie ça vaut bien pierre gaudreau
qui est candidat pour nous d'en compter
dans gala pierre gaudreau est aussi un
ancien candidat libéral ou provinciales
et conservateur au fédéral au téléphone
nous a dit connaître pierre coulombe de
l'époque de sa candidature conservatrice
en 2004 il nous a confirmé qu'il a bien
eu deux rencontres d'automne dernier
avec pierre coulombe
lors du petit-déjeuner à québec où les
deux ont parlé de projets de logements
et d'hôtels à coups de joie kesha faire
ville mais que jamais il ne lui a
transmis de l'information privilégiée
sur des projets miniers
nous lui avons demandé une entrevue
devant la caméra il ne nous a jamais
rappelés et excès c'est que au niveau
professionnel
pierre coulombe at il violé la loi sur
le lobbyisme en contrant pierre gaudreau
sans être enregistrées le commissaire au
lobbyisme maître françois casgrain crois
que non
leur nez dans d'autres dispositions le
qui normalement interdisent aux
titulaires de charges publiques de
donner une information privilégiée
d'information et de connaissance dans
l'exercice de ses fonctions peut pas
chercher à avantager quelqu'un d'autre
avec l'information qui retient qu'il
dise la vérité qu'il ait vraiment des
contacts ou qu'ils fassent seulement
ventes et des choses qui n'existaient
pas dans les deux cas c'est un crime si
fait seulement se vante une fraude d'une
tentative de fraude
si il a vraiment les contacts qu'il va
aller plus loin que ce sera une fraude
envers le gouvernement ces deux crimes
qui sont sont graves
revenons à la chambre d'hôtel les
questions de michel sur des relations de
pierre coulombe avec jean charest sont
de plus en plus direct la conférence de
l'upm devenu un jouet
tu en as pas remis de tes projets notre
rôle est beaucoup moins
chaque numéro
[Musique]
mme aubry qui a du coup d'une façon
quelque chose de dire merci car si
jamais ça a eu besoin de six à un vrai
besoin de son intervention
on développe quelque chose qu'on
s'attarde ouais parce qu'il fait parce
qu réduction
saga
même pas
gérard et marie le guen on voit un mois
vim
franchement
aucun
durant cette dernière rencontre pierre
coulon propos à michel de la compagnie à
une assemblée politique de jean charest
qui se déroulera à laval oiseaux pour la
branche la première de deux semaines
plus tard le 1er avril nous filmons
pierre coulombe qui assistent à
l'assemblée politique à laval après la
conférence sera salué jean charest qui
l'accueille comme s'il était un vieil
ami
que le gars s'est dit dans l'oreille
[Musique]
après cette brève rencontre nous
confrontons directement pierre coulombe
la sortie de la salle les informations
en enregistrement comme quoi vous tenté
de monnayer vos contacts politiques dans
le cadre du projet du projet plan nord
ce que c'est exact discutait ce que je
pouvais donner 3 4 minutes nature face à
nos questions et décide de quitter d'un
stationnement toujours le même mutisme
pierre coulombe a accepté de nous
rencontrer quelques jours plus tard mais
sans la présence de la caméra
il nous a dit essentiellement que la
politique lui permet de faire des
affaires et du réseautage
il a ajouté avoir parlé à d'autres que
michel du plan nord et dit moi je
rencontre des hommes d'affaires
le plan nord je m'intéresse à ça il
affirme avoir fait une erreur en disant
qu'il possédait de l'information
privilégiée qu'il a été naïve et
prétentieux il nous a déclaré j'ai dit
des choses que j'aurais pas dû dire pour
faire le fanfaron accès dia michel que
la façon de récompenser les politiciens
c'est de les nommer sur des conseils
d'administration il a répondu ça c'est
de mon cru pierre coulombe a confirmé
qu'il a rencontré pierre cottereau le
bras droit du ministre simard
mais a ajouté qu'il ne lui a jamais
donné d'informations privilégiées
et quand nous avons demandé à pierre
coulombe s'il a parlé de jean charest à
michel il admis que c'est possible at il
dit dans l'oreille du premier ministre
j'étais le féliciter vous at il précisé
ce que monsieur charest contredit dans
son communiqué selon sa version c'est
pour réitérer son souhait devrait au
gouvernement que monsieur coulombe s'est
adressé à lui lors de l'événement de
laval monsieur charest s'est dit choqué
à la lecture des passages que nous lui
avons transmis le premier ministre a
aussi refusé de nous accorder une
entrevue ne voulons pas accorder à cette
histoire plus d'intérêt qu'elle n'en
méritent